[Music]  president obama has been running a  contest called dinner with barack you  enter online and if you're selected you  get to have a meal with the president  well dinner with Barack has been so  successful that apparently now Joe Biden  wants in on the action yeah yeah they  have a new yeah take a look it's pretty  cool today the White House invites you  to enter a new contest called  lunch without Joe Biden it's a way for  supporters to enjoy a relaxing lunch  without Joe Biden going on and on with  one of his stories like the time his  wife Jill got a bad haircut or the one  about his dog Dutch and the squirrel he  chased it takes about 45 minutes to tell  and in the end the squirrel gets away  dear God enter now go to lunch without  Joe Biden calm let's do this  [Applause]